be careful because the machine's coming
for him they're trying to suppress
everything he's doing it's all good guys
Francis one made the right choice so now
it was
France never gonna get the fury fight
stop fighting the the pfl okay
Francis schizophary fight fight gets
announced you have his exhibition we
know it's not but he's making eight
million now he's making way more than
that okay but still that's stupid what's
he gonna do in the pfl all right so it's
just they keep moving the post well
Francis messed up but he achieves that
well okay he got that but Prince messed
up he achieved that okay but Francis
yeah you got those two but this just be
happy for the guy what do you care man
don't you want to see a guy succeed I
don't get it I don't get the hate on it
just because he left the UFC and he won
which no one's ever really done not at
this level
I'm just warning this won't be the first
time they do this exhibition not true
eight million not true what's next get
ready for it